monsieur le Premier ministre vous avez
promis d'apporter la cause de l'école à
Matignon mais de quelle école
parlez-vous celle de l'école publique
gratuite laïque et obligatoire ou celle
de l'école payante réservé à une caste
et au
beaucartier celle de la mixité sociale
ou celle de la ségrégation scolaire
celle de la laïcité qui s'impose ou
celle des cours religieux imposés
celle de l'égalité entre les sexes ou
celle des classes pour les filles et les
classes pour les garçons celle de
l'éducation civique et de l'éducation
àexuelle
ou celle qui prôent des discours
sexistes et des discours homophobes
celle de l'émancipation des élèves ou
celle de l'uniforme obligatoire celle de
l'éducation populaire ou celle du
service national universel
d'endoctrinement de la jeunesse celle du
libre choix de son
ou celle de parcours sup
contourné celle d'un enseignant devant
chaque classe ou celle à laquelle on
supprime 6500 postes depuis
2017 Monsieur le Premier Ministre la
colère gronde dans le finisterère en
iser dans le pu d'ou dans le Calvados
des classes des écoles fermes les
dotations horaires en saint aussi sont
réduites à pot de chacrin partout en
France les revendications sont les mêmes
aujourd'hui comme jeudi dernier des
dizaines de milliers d'enseignants sont
dans la rue escand tanur Amélie oua
cterra démission Amélie
oua Castera
démission Monsieur le Premier Ministre
écoutez-les pour une
fois
merci la parole est à Madame Amélie oua
casterin ministre de l'éducation
nationale de la jeunesse et des Sports
Monsieur
le monsieur le député de la porte
opposer l'école publique à l'école
privée c'est vraiment une guerre d'un
autreâge et qu'il est juste hors de
question de raviver depuis la loi de Bré
de 59 sous la présidence du général de
Gaulle les unes cohabitent avec les
autres liberté de l'enseignement et
qualité du service public de l'éducation
50 % des familles ont fait le choix à un
moment ou à un autre de mettre au moins
un de leurs enfants dans l'école privée
mais ce que je vous je veux vous
exprimer c'est la volonté qui est la
nôtre illustrée par la mobilisation de
60 effectifs d'inspection
supplémentairire pour nous assurer que
l'école privée est au rendez-vous de ces
obligations en matière pédagogique en
matière financière en matière
administrative sur le plan des du
respect des valeurs de la République et
tout particulièrement de la laïcité mais
aussi monsieur le député en matière de
mixité social et scolaire ou le
secrétariat général de l'enseignement
catholique a pris des engagements vis
vis àis de nous dont nous nous
assurerons de la bonne mise en œuvre ça
veut dire un meilleur suivi sur les
conditions d'accès aux établissement
privés ça veut dire plus de transparence
sur ces conditions d'accès ça veut dire
une amélioration du taux de boursier
c'est tout ce dispositif là dont nous
voulons nous assurer de l'effective mise
en œuvre parce que nous voulons faire
réussir toutes les écoles de ce pays
donc ce protocole qui date de mai 2023
assorti de moyens spécifiques nous
ferons en sorte qu'il y ait le bon
niveau d'exigence l'école privée mérite
des moyens ni plus ni moins que la juste
allocation que le niveau d'élèves qui
sont scolarisés à savoir 17 % dans notre
pays avec une prise en compte de
l'indice de position sociale des
établissements requier faire réussir
tous les élèves de notre pays toutes les
écoles de notre pays merci beaucoup
madame la ministre monsieur de la
porte
madame la ministre la guerre scolaire
c'est vous qui la ravivez ce n'est pas
nous c'est vous qui employez ces termes
c'est vous qui refusez de vous expliquer
c'est vous qui refusez de démissionner
c'est vous qui n'assumez m c'est vous
qui insultez les enseignants c'est votre
bilan c'est celui de votre gouvernement
maintenant écoutez les enseignants
merci